hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba please
tell Amy our Burren has returned to the
real rejects today make sure to go check
out her YouTube channel
it is poppin last time she was here just
an announcement video now it's growing a
lot and the videos are great and today
she actually gave me some candy she'd go
check out the video it'll be up on her
YouTube channel soon enough for my
girlfriend and I which will make her
very happy she loves Christmas and she
respects Hanukkah thanks I wanted to
give an intercultural interfaith again
you're gonna watch this trailer today
called in the heights you like musicals
Amy I love musicals whoa something I was
watching Avengers porn lin-manuel
miranda did the music and the lyrics
were like the huge Broadway play and
then now there's a movie here let's
check this out
that's it no story that was disappeared
sometimes
ever seen that guy I know like was
hidden Hamilton Hamilton is their roller
coaster the odds are against you but
there's a chance right
some sparkly diamond is no focus
oh damn I have nipple two little details
they tell the world we are not evil
[Music]
[Music]
oh I didn't realize it deals with like
all these subject matters oh man he's a
tear jerker I mean when think stories it
just felt like fighting for equality
inside I'm following your dream yeah and
that part there like you know a dream is
in a sparkly diamond sometimes it's
really hard and just oh man yeah like
really moving inspiring stories
especially ones that deal with the
acceptance my god those really get to me
I love it it's an ethnically diverse
cast I love it I love it we're just like
boring into my soul
but that Jimmy Smits though a meze
wearing an Empire Strikes Back shirt in
Jimmy Smits as you guys can recall is in
Star Wars and as Leia's adopted daddy oh
he is yeah remember connection I just
watched the prequels I can't remember
yeah and I think it's smart for
lin-manuel Miranda's movie adaptation to
not be Hamilton at first oh yeah
well it but it gave me such a Hamilton
like he has such a sound you know it's a
major Hamilton vibes without like oh
this sounds the same it just it felt
like him yes yes yes I loved the color
scheme they they chose it was so bright
I love you yeah you're just shooting on
the streets yeah it doesn't feel like
this crazy set production it might be
but it doesn't feel that way like it
really feels like a community yeah but
still bright and colorful Wow
just the visuals and combined with the
music in the heights that that's gonna
be the big number
loved it it was like one that you I
couldn't help I wasn't expecting to be
so moved by that
no I'm neither was i I thought it was
just gonna be like another fun looking
musical you know yeah it's gonna be a
feel-good musical with a very real
message yeah I know I brought the
ethnically diverse thing but just like
how cultural it all feel totally the
visuals of it some of it is just feels
like some great choreography and camera
dancing and stuff and I like when they
had some like weird trippy visual
moments as well but it doesn't look like
it's bombastic with that no feels like
pretty grounded yes yes it's refreshing
to get this kind of musical to I mean I
know like lamella Rhonda's voice has
really been dominating lately and none
of his work has been directly adapted he
can film he contributed to Mary Poppins
Returns but to get a musical that is
combining like you know his style which
has a lot of rapping involved that's
gonna be refreshing for the big screen I
think it had that similar sound like I
was saying to Hamilton that really just
was there here the whole thing you
mentioned the choreography even I can't
imagine the rehearsal process cuz the
smallest movements like the key streets
like we nee like Reeve grasped his keys
that Clank or jingle or whatever you
want to say it was with the music and
when he's like preparing whatever in in
his bodega with the sugar and the
whatever like it's all on beat and like
it's just that was so cool like just
thank you the detail and the thought
that went into that I obsessed that kind
of stuff that guy who could remember the
time he played doctor drain straight out
of Compton so cool and he was in black
clansmen - oh so cool like I love loves
everything I'm seeing and this director
John I'm sure he did crazy rich Asians
which was also visually stunning movie I
loved that movie
I mean I loved that movie tomorrow so he
knows how to bring energy heart humor I
think he was like a music video director
before I could be wrong about that I
think he was but then to see him doing
this would make sense right aid in that
point you know I mean you can't even
know that you say that he made Singapore
like another care
during the film like Sex in the City New
York was the fifth character and I think
that their neighborhood washing don't
hide a character yeah in the film which
I love that well that's what I meant by
how like you feel like that community
sense of community and tightness
pleasantly surprised by this trailer I
mean III had a feeling to be a good
trailer but I was like wow this looks
great this looks great I mean it doesn't
look like cats which looks there's
nothing that will match the heights of
cats Oh guys what do you think of this
trailer
are you excited also if you happen to
know I'm sure I'm like one Google search
away but you happen to know if any of
these original if these cast members
were originally in the play oh yeah
please comment below you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bow follow Amy our burn on
her YouTube channel and Instagram and I
like to end this is the patron day shots
a lovely woman named Rosa Parra I call
her the lady stark of our patreon page
she's been with us since the beginning
throughout this journey for someone who
works in the medical field she
eventually started up her own like movie
blog the sites and she's like killing it
like I love her reviews and she's a
hard-working mom latina as well so you
are perfectly suited to be shattered out
in this video my dear that's what I do
tying it in Oh Dominican Republic maybe
you're related to them even though I
think you're you know I'm just messing
with you
Rosa I love the hell out of you you are
easily one of my favorite people in the
world thank you so much for being you
you're just great Amy would you like to
say something kinda Rosa well I mean
Greg here has some fabulous things to
say about you so hi Rosa I wish you all
the best
I'll check out your stuff yeah you did
it you said nice things I did say nice
things
Merry Christmas and say how does your
family for me especially Cassandra cause
I know she prefers me
John one of the few make sure to say
Merry Christmas to her specifically for